[Music]
the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now or next
our media group
to be clear this doesn't stop with
donald trump
tonight on politics now president trump
impeached again
the votes from nevada's delegation and
where things go in the senate
a nevada assemblyman caught up on a
campaign finance
scandal what we know about the police
investigation into alex asepha
i believe that we should really focus on
a plan let's get some sort of plan in
place
and then continue working on distance
learning
and is it back to school or back to the
computer the ccsd school board vote on
trying to put children back in the
classroom
[Music]
from 8 news now this is politics now
thank you very much for joining us i'm
john langler donald trump has been
impeached for a second time
now it's up to the senate to determine
if the president actually gets convicted
the house of representatives voted
232-197 to impeach president trump
for inciting an insurrection of the u.s
capitol ten republicans joined the
democrats
most of the gop though argued for unity
in the president's defense even if some
admitted that he bears some
responsibility
a vote to impeach will further fan the
flames
of partisan division the terrorists who
stormed this building
plan to hang the vice president kill the
speaker and topple our government
democrats argued even with less than a
week left in president trump's term
a senate conviction would likely bar him
from ever running for president
again so here's how nevada's
congressional delegation voted on
impeachment
democrats dina titus susie lee and
stephen horsford supported the
impeachment in the house
nevada's lone republican congressman
mark amade voted against it
congressman horsford says he wants to go
even further
to be clear this doesn't stop with
donald trump
there are 121 members of congress
who also participated some of them it is
as more information is becoming more
available
that may actually have facilitated the
insurrection
um so they need to be held accountable
they need to be expelled
and removed uh from office we have heads
of
agencies that need to be held
accountable any individual
from the president to an agency to a
member of congress who is involved in
inciting insurrection
against the united states must be held
accountable
president donald trump the only
president in american history to be
impeached
twice and to talk about that and where
we go from here we're joined by our
washington correspondent alexander limon
alex
let's get right into things what are the
chances the senate takes up the
impeachment trial before the president
leaves office
well that's not going to happen uh
senator mitch mcconnell already
announced that he will not be calling
the senate back from rhesus to begin an
impeachment trial immediately
so that means that likely it will happen
after joe biden
is inaugurated so the purpose of that
would be to try to prevent president
trump from running for office again in
the future if he is convicted
now the timing and logistics of all of
it is going to be pretty tricky because
obviously the new president joe biden is
going to try to be getting his
agenda off the ground trying to get
cabinet members confirmed through the
senate maybe even trying to pass
a coveted release bill so we've actually
heard from joe biden on this topic and
he said he's had conversations with the
top senators
to try to figure out if they can
essentially divide their days in half
and deal with his legislative agenda for
half the day
and then deal with the senate
impeachment trial of president trump for
the other half of the day so that's
a lot to take on so we likely have you
know some pretty busy days and weeks
ahead of us here on capitol hill
it seems as though there might still be
up in the air if there's going to be an
appetite to continue with this process
when president biden takes office next
week
as you mentioned there's a lot on his
agenda as well
any gauging on whether the appetite will
sustain itself into the next
administration
yeah there is some mixed reaction
obviously uh republicans
are among those who are saying this is
unnecessary you will no longer be
in the white house um some democrats as
well wonder if it is the wisest path to
move forward but on the other hand we
are also hearing from
top democrats who say there needs to be
some sort of consequence because
obviously now president trump has been
impeached for
inciting a riot in which members of the
public we now know were trying to
assassinate some of the top members
of congress so they say they can't just
let that slide and they do feel that
a senate impeachment trial to try to
convict the president does still need to
happen
and that was alexander limon from
washington d.c as we mentioned mark
amada nevada's only
no vote against the article of
impeachment in a statement the
republican
said the article of impeachment is not
strongly drafted due primarily to an
objective
which is he says the ends justify the
means the fledgling investigation he
says
is already verifying that those who led
the perpetrators were hardly driven to
action within an hour of the riot
beginning
i vote no congressman dina titus
says she was worried that violence in
the capital could spread all the way
here to nevada
i do worry about it because people are
encouraged to take action in their own
hands and we are a government of laws
and that's what we should follow when
when we saw people storming the capital
uh who would have ever
imagined that to be the case and we have
a constitutional duty i swore
when i was uh elected to protect the
constitution
and the government and and that's not
what happened last wednesday
and one of the reasons trump needs to go
that he's still a danger
is that he could pardon all these people
and he controls the nuclear button
we'll have more on the inauguration and
the security steps being taken in
washington
later in the program now to the state
legislature metro police are
recommending charges against a now
formal
former nevada assemblyman over a
campaign finance issue
and for not living in his district this
week assemblyman alex assefa resigned
while facing those charges
the democrat represented district 42
that's essentially spring valley
he's also thought to be the first
american elected to public office here
in the u.s
this week metro police told the i-team
they recommended the district attorney
charge asepha with two dozen
counts they're related to his not living
in his district
misusing campaign funds burglary and
theft
prosecutors though have not filed the
charges just yet
a second seat in the legislature also
needs to be filled but for a very
different reason
state senator ivana kinsella is
resigning to join the biden
administration
cancella is joining the u.s department
of health and human services
the democrat was a senior adviser to the
biden campaign during the election
before joining the state senate she was
the political director for the culinary
union
cancella represented district 10 that
includes mccarran airport
and portions of the las vegas strip both
replacements will be picked by the clark
county commission the candidates will
have to apply they have to live in the
district obviously and be democrats
the legislative session starts february
1st
clark county school students are going
to stay largely in distance learning
however this week ccsd trustees took
small steps towards reopening schools
superintendent dr jesus jarrah and the
trustees will allow the return of small
groups
on a voluntary basis sasha loftis
explains what happened in this week's
board meeting
the clark county school district is
taking small steps
towards reopening schools i am worried
about their education i feel like
they're getting cheated
it's a decision many parents call long
overdue
after months of distance learning
struggles and trustees
previous moves to delay any action the
younger kids just
it's really hard not having
that teacher or that assistant there
just to keep them on track
two votes were passed during thursday's
regular board meeting
the first approved an agreement with the
clark county education association
to lay groundwork for an eventual k
through third grade hybrid transition
i believe that we should really focus on
a plan let's get some sort of plan in
place
and then continue working on distance
learning
the second which was unanimous will
allow principals to bring students who
need
extra support back to campus in small
groups
on a limited basis because there's no
such thing as a comprehensive plan and i
think that we all know that being adults
that said we need i think we need hope
there's still no word on a timeline but
families tell us
they want to see concrete change so
their kids
can succeed i think that you're doing
them a
huge injustice by the not being
to get an education at school
that was sasha loftus reporting trustees
also heard a report seeing 90 percent of
ccsd schools assigned
more failing grades this year than last
year 2019-2020
it's a key reason that principals are
being allowed to bring struggling
students
back to campus for help coming up next
here on politics now our elected
officials jumping the line
the i-team's vanessa murphy looks into
who is and who is not
getting the covet vaccine in nevada plus
planning a safe inauguration
the extra security measures being put in
place
consultation and 40 off welcome back
to politics now
it is a lingering question as nevada and
the nation fight the coronavirus
when can people get the vaccine well
this week plants changed
the new plan outlined by governor steve
sisolak divides nevadans into two lanes
frontline workers and the general public
when you get the vaccine depends on
which one of those two groups you're in
front line workers are getting the
vaccine now they'll be able to go
into two large vaccination centers that
are opening this week
and they're all by appointment people 70
years of age and older can also
sign up for an appointment to get a
vaccine at that location
if you're in the general population
right now in that lane and you're under
the age of 70
you're going to get a vaccine from your
pharmacy health officials say once a
vial is open they really have to use it
and some businesses with a lot of
frontline workers are able to vaccinate
all their employees
i think one really important concept to
understand
is that the storage and handling of the
vaccine is incredibly difficult
and challenging and after a vial is
punctured
there's a very short window to
essentially use that
those doses within the vial before they
expire essentially
for now people can fill out a vaccine
interest form that'll notify them when
they can get that vaccine
we have a link to the form and where you
can sign up for an appointment if you're
a front-line worker
or you're over the age of 70 everything
you need is at eightnewsnow.com
elected officials in some cities are
also getting the vaccine
even if the cdc has them at a lower
priority
the i-team's vanessa murphy has that
story
some viewers contacted us to say
something doesn't seem quite right about
how the city of henderson is handling
the vaccine
the concern is whether elected officials
jumped
the line coronavirus vaccines that are
being distributed throughout
the united states right now including
right here in henderson
some city of henderson employees
including elected officials could get
vaccinated as early as january 4th
alongside frontline workers like
firefighters and police
a spokeswoman tells the i-team elected
officials are
critical to city operations but
according to the southern nevada health
district
public officials were in tier two behind
front line workers not alongside them in
the state's new vaccination plan
released monday
the health district says public
officials still fall in the second
group there's confusion to say the least
according to the cdc the state is far
behind in vaccinating nevadans
the i-team asked the governor about this
why
is this since we have known that we
would need a vaccination plan and why
has it taken so long
to come up with this newer playbook well
it hasn't taken
so long vanessa really come up with it
you know we've been planning this for a
long time we did not have the resources
the i-team also reached out to other
cities in southern nevada and clark
county
to find out where public officials fall
in their vaccination plants
here's what they told us in clark county
umc
directly received vaccine doses for
health care workers and first responders
the county is not administering the
vaccine
employees and elected officials are
expected to follow guidelines
the city of las vegas points to the
health district as the lead
and the vaccine is being rolled out to
first responders like
hospital staff fire and law enforcement
in north las vegas
firefighters emt's police officers and
corrections staff were vaccinated first
critical infrastructure employees like
elected officials
can get vaccinated starting wednesday
boulder city confirms no council members
have received the vaccine through the
city at this point
mayor kiernan mcmanus saying quote i
plan to follow the recommendations for
vaccination based on my age
without regard to my position as mayor
that would place me
in tier four end quote a different
approach
from the city of henderson deeply we
appreciate the incredible strength and
spirit that you've shown
during this unparalleled year in a
follow-up email a spokeswoman for the
city of henderson
insists the mayor and city council fall
within tier one
because they make crucial decisions for
the city you can read more of her
response
at eight newsnow dot com vanessa murphy
8 news now
in another follow-up email the city of
henderson spokesperson insisted that the
mayor and council fall within tier 1 as
vanessa just mentioned
and she also mentioned that the city has
returned vials it hasn't used to the
health district and again you can find
more details at eightnewsnow.com
a man both loved and hated coming up on
politics now we're going to take a look
at the life of casino magnate sheldon
adelson
after he passed away earlier this week
and protecting the next president the
extra security measures being taken
to keep inauguration day safe
this is the moment
you're watching politics now
the inauguration of president-elect joe
biden is next week
officials in washington are stepping up
security after the capitol hill riot
january 6th
the fbi is warning police departments
nationwide need to be ready for armed
protests at their capitol buildings on
wednesday
in nevada law enforcement agencies are
not identifying what specific
precautions will be taken
here meanwhile metro police are
investigating if any officers
took part in last week's capitol hill
riot sheriff joe lombardo says if they
did
they could lose their job we're working
hand in hand with the fbi
and we're going through all the videos
and relying on people to call in if they
know
and we'll do an intensive follow-up if
in fact we do identify somebody
right now metro police tells us they
have no evidence that any of its
officers
were inside the capitol henderson and
north las vegas police departments both
say they were not aware of any officers
that also took part in those capitol
hill riots
so what precautions are being taken in
washington d.c
our d.c bureau's raquel martin tells us
the unprecedented security measures
ahead of the inauguration
joseph robinette biden jr less than a
week before joe biden is sworn in as the
next president
the nation's capital has transformed
from a tourist attraction
to a military zone i'm very appreciative
ohio democratic senator sherrod brown
who will attend next week's ceremony
says he welcomes extra security
following last week's deadly
insurrection
i have concerns that a number of these
these mobsters these violent far
right-wing
white supremacists will come back with
guns
local and federal law enforcement
including the secret service have
already shut down nearby streets
and the pentagons deployed thousands of
national guardsmen
by inauguration day 20 thousand troops
will occupy the area
many armed thursday vice president pence
visited fema headquarters to be briefed
on inauguration day security
the american people deserve
a safe inauguration in wednesday night
president trump delivered his most
forceful statement to date against
violence
mob violence goes against everything i
believe in
and everything our movement stands for
i'm not afraid of taking him
outside president-elect biden says his
team is also receiving security
briefings
we need to go back and review everything
in the meantime republicans and
democrats are demanding an investigation
to prevent future domestic attacks it's
unclear exactly
when military troops will leave the
nation's capital but
by inauguration day there will be more
military troops in washington d.c
than currently in iraq and afghanistan
combined
for now in washington raquel martin back
to you
and we'll of course cover inauguration
day right here on channel eight our
coverage begins at five o'clock on
inauguration day morning
and will last throughout the day a man
both loved
and hated coming up next we're going to
take a look at the life of casino magnet
sheldon adelson
after his passing earlier
[Music]
casino czar sheldon adelson passed away
this week
he arrived in las vegas back in the
1980s running what was at the time
our largest convention adelson became
one of the world's richest men
a major player in las vegas a
philanthropist and a huge
republican donor joe moeller looks back
at adelson's legacy
just two things in life billionaire las
vegas casino mogul sheldon adelson
passed away monday
while born in boston in 1933 a good
portion of his life was las vegas
in the late 80s he purchased the sands
hotel and casino which eventually was
replaced by the venetian
then he built the palazzo las vegas
sands also expanded with several resorts
in asia
our city and our state
is such such a better place
because of sheldon adelson steve hill
ceo of the las vegas convention and
visitors authority recognized adelson's
impact
he had a tremendous influence on what we
do
on the meetings in convention industry
adelson also helped bring the state's
first nfl team to las vegas it's
important to point out
that mr allison was was really the
driving force behind the legion stadium
the billionaire was a veteran and a
major financial contributor to the
republican party and
president trump adelson and his wife
miriam were well-known philanthropists
donating millions to anti-drug and
jewish organizations
there are many many things that mr
adelson and dr alason
have been involved in their philanthropy
journey in
medical breakthrough in the connection
between the jewish people
all around the continuity of the jewish
people
all around the world joe muller 8 news
now
adelson was buried at the mount of
olives in jerusalem friday morning
we have a lot more on sheldon adelson in
his life here in las vegas on eight
newsnow dot com
ron futrell looks at his role in
bringing the las vegas raiders here and
building a legion stadium
and george knapp uses his own interviews
with sheldon adelson
to examine his legacy adelson was also
an extremely influential player in the
republican political world
among the things he pushed for and
accomplished adelson became the largest
known individual donor in electoral
history
in 2012. he spent 90 million dollars on
republicans in that presidential race
the money mostly went through super pacs
essentially adelson was the main backer
of the republican jewish coalition
the group helped expand the jewish
republican voting base during that time
they also had their yearly meeting at
the venetian he was also extremely
influential in getting the us embassy in
israel moved to jerusalem
and of course he was the owner of the
local newspaper the las vegas review
journal
the first major paper to endorse
then-candidate donald trump for
president of the united states
here's what to watch this week governor
steve sisilak will air his state of the
speech
at the state of the state address six
o'clock on tuesday the 19th
the republican rebuttal will be done by
assembly republican
leader dr robin titus we're going to
carry both live right here on channel 8.
the inauguration of president joe biden
is on tuesday we're going to watch that
as well
our wednesday i beg your pardon it's
also uh on capitol hill in carson city
we're going to keep an eye on the
security there
law enforcement says they do expect
armed protests nationwide
on inauguration day thank you very much
for watching us here on politics now
you can stay up to date on all the
political news online at 8newsnow.com
we're back with you every saturday stay
safe and have a good rest of your
[Music]
weekend
[Music]
you